all right we're now live and people are
coming in
welcome everybody hi everyone
thank you for coming
um you have october 21st perfect great
i'm going to hop right in there
all right i'll wait for everyone to slow
stream in i'm not sure if everyone gets
in at once
or if soon likes to make us like feel
like we're anticipating as the number
ticks up slowly i don't know if that's a
gimmick or that's legit
as people come in if it's a server issue
so i'll just give everyone a moment
okay and we'll sit here
awkwardly in silence i guess because you
know we're in zoom so it's kind of hard
too big
hey how's it going oh i want to check i
usually try to watch the attendees i try
to find the names let's see
who's here yeah we encourage people to
say in the chat where you're tuning in
from yes so either in the chat or the
slack channel which we'll
mention the section a little bit tell us
where you're coming from so we have
people from all over the world because
it's virtual
oh ken brooks good to see you ken
let's see i've got some people oh lots
of chat great i love this where'd my
chat window go though
ah some people from new york of course
portland i saw brooklyn
cupertino algiers we have melbourne
let's see a few of edinburgh who would
have thought our speaker medibro get
some people from edinburgh here
yeah i know some of them nice
all right usually nyc but currently
arlington texas i get that
quebec or quebec peninsula going to
pronounce it
germany winchester
all the new yorkers i'm not mentioning
you cause you're always you know from
there so often
that's what we're based out of milan oh
ricardo hey hey ricardo
all right i think we have a bit of a
critical mouse mask people still trickle
in
as we go but we'll slowly get started
we'll get started our announcements
so let's do that first so as always
folks i like to say
who's hiring but as the past few months
we can't have people just shout it out
so if you go to the slack and amanda
posted a link to the slack as my
hackard.org
slack there's a link in there if you go
to slack you can go post a job
um we actually had a job posting a thing
earlier today so anyone who wants to
hire people
post the jobs there anyone want who
wants to get hired go check out the jobs
that are posted
i'm very happy that throughout the years
the decade that this meetup's been along
we've gotten so many people's jobs
simply by saying who's hiring
it really works wonders so go get work
go find people to do work for you i'm
really excited for that
all right so jobs hopefully people post
it post it today post it later whenever
you feel like it
as usual we want to keep this
conversation going we have the chat
window here
in zoom but also we have this whole
slack community
so there is a slack channel the same
slack link you had earlier
and the slack channel is called oct for
october
21 meetup so if you search for that in
the channels you could join that
and if you have questions about this
about what's going on
going there you want to chat with each
other just make snarky not snarky
comments fun comments go in there
if you want to ask a question for
questions um since we obviously can't
save the questions for the end well we
could save them but we can't ask them
all together
go ahead and ask them preferably in the
slack or if you need to in the in the
zoom
chat and we will collate them and we
will ask the question
of katarina a little bit later at the
end uh so put all of your questions in
zoom and
in slack and we will go through them and
ask them all for you
those of you who are regulars know how
important pizza is to this meetup
so i got mine today from a place called
um proof
it looks like it's a round pie but it's
actually a um a square pie rectangular
is what they should call it
it they call it a brooklyn pie but i'd
call it more of a well yeah it's not a
grandma since it doesn't have like
crushed tomatoes
i'll call it whatever brooklyn pie is i
don't think they call this brooklyn pie
in
new york but we'll call it that so
everyone is an
amateus got from williamsburg pizza
williamsburg pizza and it's cold because
i like whole pizza
and i don't remember what kind it is but
it looks really good but that's
actually from brooklyn so you know at
least something's really from brooklyn
yeah well not that particular size but
the place you went to williamsburg pizza
originated
in williamsburg so hope everyone hope
everyone has at home has their pizza as
well
because we all know that is the
lifeblood of
the world um ricardo
milan i hope you got some pizza there
and i will argue that pizza really
hit its genesis in new york and sort of
it sort of
had the spark in naples but it's really
a new york food and i will live i will
die on that hill
so a few events coming up
next month we have henrik talking about
the future package he wrote the future
package
which it underlies a lot of parallelism
especially what you would use when using
the fur package
which was just updated by davis a day or
two ago so you want to learn about how
to use
the future which in future package which
exposes futures
come check out that meetup that is
november 9th
next month we will announce it in the
next few days
in december kicking off another r week
for this year
december 1st is will landau talking
about targets
some of you might remember from a few
months ago we i think miles mcbain was
talking
about how to use the drake package will
wrote the drake package and he has since
decided he's going to make the next
version of it and call it targets
so you want to learn how to use targets
and how it differs from drake
come december 1st and that kicks off
we're doing another virtual conference
this year normally we have a conference
in washington dc
but this year since we're not going
anywhere we decided to make it a really
focused conference
so december 2nd and 4th yes the day
after that meetup we are doing an
r in government conference this is for
all levels of government both american
government and outside american
government
um it's federal local state provincial
parliamentary whatever different
governments you have it's all government
focused we have people from
the nih from nasa from various
government organizations and ngos we
have people from
the united states army we have people
from all sorts of different walks
of government life and we are announcing
tomorrow on the website
it's brand new he's been a regular he's
always the keynote at new york r
but this year we have andrew gellman
giving a politically charged talks we
all know he's a famous political
scientist
he's gonna give a very politically
charged talk just a short month after
the election so it's gonna be fun to see
what he has to talk about
uh he will be announced on the website
tomorrow we're very excited to have him
he always puts on a great show at nyr so
we're very excited
so remember november 9th we have a
meetup december 1st we have a meetup
december 2nd through 4th we have the
government conference including
workshops that are government focused
we have john hirsch giving machine
learning for public policy
we have malcolm and um malcolm
mckay oh my god his last name i'm
scooping on malcolm barrett
and lucy d'agostino talking about causal
analysis
and then cass akamoto giving a workshop
about
mapping for public policy so
we are very very excited for these
workshops and these conferences and all
these events so reminder
ask your questions in slack and we will
call it the questions for katarina
and then come the next few months and
just sort of hang out
enjoy and we're going to put on another
social meetup at some point we did it
last month
purely social meetup we're going to do
it again it's got a we got to just get
the timing right
so with that one of the glory did i
forget anything oh
equal health alliance thank you equal
health alliance for providing the zoom
link it's been really helpful they've
been providing the zoom link since march
um they do research infectious diseases
so it goes nicely
um no one who is one of the regulars
meek health alliance has actually done
research on coronaviruses so it's really
cool to have them helping us out
it's very helpful having to zoom like
enabling us all to do this
so with that one of the silver linings
of
this pandemic is that we could have
speakers and attendees
from all around the world um i think
miles set the record coming from
australia we're not going to have anyone
farther away than that but coming from
across the ocean
we have katarina coming to us from
edinburgh we're very excited to hear her
talk so everyone a big virtual round of
applause for katarina thank you
thanks jared thank you
so let's see if i can share my screen
okay um
so this does not seem to be letting me
do much
[Music]
so we saw your screen but it looks like
you're like your note slide
yeah so let me see if i can do something
else
and just one second
okay let's see if i share now
how's that does that work it looks like
we're seeing beamer or something
yeah so this is a pdf of uh stuff i'm
about to
share that's right you're all set okay
cool
um yeah so hi everyone and
thanks so much for tuning in from all
these places around the
the world um the topic i wanted to
share with you today has to do with data
validation and r
um just a few things about me before we
actually
dive in so i work as a data scientist at
tesco bank
um actually my background is in
psychology
which is pretty much how i first
found out about r that was around 2012
and i've stuck with it ever since i was
quite a surprise at the time
i'd never done any any programming so
quite the revelation that
i really ended up uh loving it uh during
these degrees in psychology
and uh so much so that that's pretty
much uh
what i work with today my main tool
um a few uh years ago maybe one or two
years ago
uh and for maybe about four prior to
that
i used to organize the r meetup in
edinburgh
which is still going strong by the way
some people from
edinburgh from the meetup are actually
tuning in
tonight so if you're ever in the
neighborhood
please make sure to check them out or
attend any meetings that would be super
awesome
um and okay having having said all that
um just a few quick words about why data
validation where
did the whole idea behind this talk even
come from
i think the first time i actually looked
into this
or um the idea started to kind of pop up
that oh this is this is a really
interesting and important topic i should
maybe look into this a bit further
was at a user conference quite some time
ago
but after that it kind of sat at the
back of my head
on the back burner until much more
recently
at tesco bank until um a project popped
up where this became
very very important and that's kind of
at the foundation of
of this talk and what really motivated
the
exploration journey that um
fed into all the content i've i've
thrown into these slides
so having said all that what i've
included are some definitions
some principles there's quite a hefty
conceptual component to this talk and
i'm actually going to argue that that's
possibly the most important part of this
talk
even more so than any r
components necessarily but those are are
included as well so don't worry
um i'll also go over some criteria so
some general things about
what you might want to look at or
consider whenever you're
building or designing the validation
rules that should apply to your data
a bunch of dedicated packages that have
to do with data validation from the r
ecosystem
i'm sure there's more out there but
these are part of the roundup
that i prepared for uh right now some
additional tools that are not
necessarily
full-blown packages on the topic and
after that
i'll round up with some conclusions
figured i should maybe start a timer as
well
so uh if we dive in with the definitions
first
possibly unsurprisingly data validation
is the fact of checking the quality of
source data before acting
on the data in any particular way
interestingly enough i've been
coming across various definitions that
have to do with or mention the fact
that data validation has something to do
with how accurate the data is or how
correct it is
and actually that's not something i
personally agree with
and it's possible i'll make various
statements that might lead to some
discussion at the end so it's really
unfortunate that this is remote
but we'll see how that goes um always
curious to hear people's input or
discuss things
but yeah so there is a distinction to be
made there in between
whether or not your data has passed a
sequence of validation tests
and whether or not it's actually
accurate or correct or valid
and basically this is where my
psychology background
really comes into play so imagine a
situation where you might have
a data set that has human participants
as
cases and in the absence of any
information having to do with say
their date of birth you have just ages
you won't be able
through any data validation rules
or processes to identify whether or not
somebody's age is maybe
60 or 61 uh formally speaking which is
what
data validation is really about uh you
won't be able to distinguish in between
one or the other in terms of correctness
and that's a really powerful idea also
in psychology in terms of classical test
theory so that has to do with thinking
of
any piece of observed data having to do
with
especially when we're thinking about
scales or questionnaire data those sorts
of things
every individual data point is basically
made up of a true score and
error and you can never fully quantify
or figure out the sources of of error
and that's basically not something data
validation
can help with so it's important to
always remember that
um also because of um
some similarities with data cleaning i
wanted to also distinguish it from that
is it the same not quite i would argue
um
to my mind data cleaning has much more
to do with
um one-off maybe quick and dirty i hope
that's fair to say
fixes in the here and now whereas data
validation
is more of a step that allows you to
future proof your pipeline that you're
working with
and basically anticipate ways in which
various
problems might arise and always be
notified if that happens
rather than deal with some kind of
static data set
clean it once and then basically job
done
the other distinction to be weary of is
there are
data cleaning kind of by definition
means that you are
active acting upon the data and fixing
whatever seems to be
off about it whereas data validation
doesn't necessarily imply
anything like that you might just be
better off depending on your context and
we're going to see a bit more about that
later
you might be better off just signaling
that
something is off about the data but not
actually changing it in any way
so having covered all that if we now
dive into some actual
principles um hopefully that will go
down
well as it's quite um theoretical but
i'm
i'm fairly sure that um almost everybody
if not everybody will come will be
convinced by the end of this section
uh of the value of covering this
first so
the the main inspiration for this entire
section
is steve mcconnell's code complete book
which is really um
quite famous so interestingly enough
data validation
in this book is a section that falls
under the banner of defensive
programming
which is pretty much the coding
equivalent of
um basically looking both ways whenever
you're crossing a street even though
cars should only in theory come from one
side but basically you want to prepare
for the worst even most unusual
circumstances because you want to build
software that is about as robust as
possible so that's kind of the
underlying idea
there um something also that is
um essential and also felt
quite striking to me while i was going
over the material in this book is that
when you're designing software it could
be a shiny app or
what have you it doesn't even have to be
language specific that's basically the
whole idea of why these principles are
important because they're applicable
across a variety of contexts context
languages
is that the so often quoted garbage in
garbage out motto
doesn't really apply in the world of
data validation what's actually
much more important is that a good
program should never put out garbage
regardless of what it takes
in so that's that's kind of the the key
principle
that underlies everything that's going
to follow in this talk
so some better alternatives uh steve
mcconnell would
argue and i would agree are garbage in
nothing out or basically rather than
nothing maybe
an app or whatever you're designing
should use uh
the last known reliable
data that it has but not really acts in
any particular way on the new data that
is problematic
garbage in error message out or simply
no garbage allowed in
and this ladder option is basically what
we ended up implementing
in an app at tesco so
um having said that it's probably
already
starting to look like quite a lot of
effort is involved in
figuring out how to design code that is
consistent with all these rules and
principles and more often than not
the types of projects that people i feel
um end up having to work on have to do
with something completely different it
could be
forecasting some sort of time series
doing classification what have you and
anything else that has to do
with constructing a mechanism
for data validation is kind of going to
be a satellite problem that might be
left behind so why should you care about
this
uh and you know spend time and effort on
it
well i have a couple of examples or
coding horror stories uh lined up that
hopefully will convince you that
it is well worth the effort and the time
that you might
uh put in so first example
uh both of these examples by the way are
things that actually happened to me
um whether or not i was actually the
perpetrator
or the coder so the first one um
a true story um happened to me but i
didn't have anything to do with the
actual uh
system that created the issue so in a
health care system from a country i
won't actually
name what ended up happening was
i ended up getting some medical tests
done didn't hear anything back
from for a while and at some point i
received a letter
that was really quite alarming and
surprising
that whatever results um
actually um it couldn't
uh it didn't make sense something
something like that was in the letter
and i had to go back and uh redo the
test
which was uh very unusual and
sent me quite in this kind of uh
state of panic i thought what could this
mean this seems very
very bizarre maybe the results were
really bad and
they thought they couldn't possibly be
right so that's why they want to recheck
things
but what it later turned out being after
a pointless
uh appointment that i had to make was
that
um the way the system they had
operated it wasn't checking for
duplicated records interestingly enough
and what happened was somebody had
already typed up my results
on for one case so for the same patient
id and the same date
what happened afterwards for some reason
somebody else started to type in
the same results yet again but for some
reason didn't finish that record
and whenever the system ended up having
to act upon this
it was only the incomplete fishy looking
record that was taken into account and
that's why i had to in theory go back in
and redo the whole procedure so that was
actually really quite surprising instead
of stood out in my mind in terms of
something so small that you might be
tempted to
ignore or have as an afterthought
whenever you're running a project can
have in some cases like this real
um consequences so that was that was one
of the things i wanted to cover
but the next one sadly has more to do
with um
me making the same sort of mistake and
um rushing towards a deadline but
actually
um still planning to do
data validation and get into it at some
point but
still leaving it kind of as an
afterthought and thinking well
i'll get to it and before i actually do
hopefully everything will be fine
there's nothing really to worry about
except there was because
before i ever had a chance to really
look into data validation
something unusual did occur and that was
in the case of data formats
so without going into too much detail
the app i'm talking
about that i was working on at the time
relied on having users
upload data um regularly
and upon this data then it was supposed
to
do some modeling various types of
processing output graphs all sorts of
things like that
um this was all time series uh related
and what ended up happening at one point
was uh
users notified us that for some reason
it looked like the app
wasn't updating any any outputs and
why why was that the case so immediately
once you get something like that you're
tempted to think
well it sounds like probably what
happened
is the upload or data storage mechanism
is buggy something is unusual there but
after wasting
quite a while looking into that and not
finding anything wrong there
what turned out to actually have been
the case was that
because we weren't validating data
formats
that particular time the data format had
suddenly changed whenever
uh the users were uploading this um
and the gist of what happened next was
these dates had been in the time
series had been converted to nas further
down the line
uh somewhere else had been removed by
list wise deletion and that's why the
behavior
observable to users was that there was
no new data
apparently even though they had uploaded
it so that's again why it's
really important to make sure that you
have
expectations that are made explicit as
part of a suite of validation
tests otherwise you can end up either
sending people
to appointments for nothing uh panicking
that who knows what might be wrong with
them
or situations where you're
going on this wild goose chase for a bug
that actually doesn't exist
because something completely different
that you didn't think to
catch was going on so having
covered that and hopefully clarified or
or convinced you
why validation is really important
actually
um i wanted to say a few things about um
data validation principles and in terms
of how to decide
um how exactly to implement data
validation
routines so if you think about all these
types of scenarios
like the ones that i just mentioned
[Music]
whenever you're diving into a new
project and thinking about
creating new software you need to start
to think explicitly about
okay in the case of bad inputs what
given the context of what you're
designing and what it's supposed to do
what should it ideally do in terms of
bad inputs should it
halt abruptly in some cases maybe that
is preferable
uh or should it just keep going
it's it's an open question but unless
you're actually
made aware of these things from the
start um
you might not put effort into things um
and or basically dedicate enough
attention to them they might just end up
being uh running away from you because
of deadlines because of everything else
that has to be done so that's really
again why
i wanted to emphasize this component of
the talk much more
okay having said that uh two key ways
of um dealing with data validation are
error handling and the other one will be
assertions
so error handling uh that has
various forms in r could mean a bunch of
things
again it depends exactly on what you're
building and what you think makes sense
for your particular
particular scenario so in one case you
might
uh replace anything unusual with a
so-called neutral value if that makes
sense
or you might return a previous answer
or which is what we ended up doing in
one app recently display an error
message
to the user so that they know why the
input they provided is
doesn't fit the expectations of
everything else that we built
um and assertions are basically
what the r packages i'll talk about have
to
uh have to do with um
having covered all that what should you
do with these things are there
situations where error handling is more
appropriate
than assertions or vice versa well
according to code complete yes um and
here's where things might get slightly
dicey and hopefully you'll see why there
might be some slight differences in
between
the code complete world which is written
by somebody with experience
in visual basic c plus plus
java and working at microsoft versus the
data science world where the types of
problems or software
might be substantially different but
we'll see about that
in in a second so uh this
kind of standard uh dev view
holds that error handling should be used
when you want to check for bad data
and especially for conditions that you
expect to occur and
can foresee as being possible so
here we might have something like um
in our scenario maybe a time series is
way too short
and uh if it's a time series for sales
maybe in some cases here and there you
might get the occasional time series
that is just
zero sales from start to finish um or or
any sort of issue like that
that might make things misbehave
so if you can kind of foresee anything
like that
and it comes from um external less
trusted data sources then
the code complete way is um
you're supposed to use error handling to
deal with that however
assertions on the other other hand are i
feel
where things deviate most um
or can deviate most from the world of
data science so basically the argument
here
is that
whenever somebody let's say if i were to
give an example
um somebody might use um
some refactoring on an older piece of
code
and accidentally end up changing the
sorts of output that come from that
function
which will lead to unforeseen
consequences further down the line
so in this case even if uh
previously the source of the data was a
trusted source
something has changed and if you have an
assertion in place to say
the output of this function is supposed
to formally have these characteristics
and then suddenly it doesn't
that will allow you to say okay a bug
has been
inserted here and it'll be much easier
to figure out
where exactly it came from rather than
the fact that it might produce
very bizarre effects way further down
the line and then you'll have a much
harder time figuring out where it came
from so that's the argument of
where to use assertions under this kind
of context and code complete
the rest all skip over because they
actually
overlap quite well with data science
stuff
so as i was saying things are not
necessarily quite so simple we can deal
with other scenarios as well
and the key
difference here is the use of assertions
so if previously encode complete we had
seen something to do
with assertions you should use for
situations that normally should never
occur but because we're being defensive
we want to make sure that these are in
place and catch anything
out of the ordinary even though it
shouldn't normally happen
in this case like in the example i was
giving with the shiny app with the date
formats
the data isn't to be trusted yet we
still have some expectations about it
so we can formalize them in assertions
so even if this is different i don't
think this is
um this is a problem so in this case
assertions could basically go
either way hopefully that made
made sense in terms of
[Music]
the kind of meeting point uh in between
worlds
you're probably better off maybe even
actually doing both so even if you have
a problem that's been spotted in your
code
or an assertion that has failed you can
also handle it so that basically
the software you build is as robust as
possible
so that's pretty much what we ended up
implementing in
in our app um
just a few quick notes about when or
where to validate
usually as early as possible if that
would work
for example if somebody submits a new
data set that has
names that are unusual or deviate
from what is expected based on previous
data
as soon as the upload comes in you're
able to flag something like that
um i'm also wary of time and all the
content that maybe i kind of got
slightly carried away with so i might
start skipping over some things a bit
faster if that's okay
um and leave it open to questions at the
end in case somebody spots anything that
is interesting to them and they want to
know more
um the other the other idea or uh
visualization that you you might want to
just basically
hold on to again once you're in a
position of
writing new software is that
code can be compartmentalized in a safe
zone
and a non-safe zone so basically
depending on
which area you're situating yourself in
either immediately after the upload
let's say in a shiny app which might be
justifiably a non-safe zone you might
want to handle things in one way
versus further down the line once in
theory
all the unusualness of the data will
have been handled
one way or another and the code assumes
to be working with
correct data or let's say formally
correct data given what i've been
mentioning at the very top
the start of this talk so having
said that um how exactly
might you want to deal with an issue
whenever it does occur
even if all the previous stuff i've been
mentioning has had to do with defensive
programming
offensive programming might have its own
uses here especially in the development
part of the of the cycle
so if anything unusual happens
ideally you want to know and you want to
know as soon as possible so basically
you want things to fail hard um
however that's not always the case for
anything more minor it is actually
fine to uh deal with the issues
um silently for anything like let's say
duplicated columns or duplicated cases
you can just strip these without
actually having to
say uh log any uh errors in case of
failed assertions or anything like that
if it's if it's minor stuff
okay luckily that's all over uh
with hopefully everybody is still uh
with us and still awake
after all that um in terms of the actual
criteria
it might be well worth going over these
just so you have
um a rough plan of the sorts of things
you might want to consider
when designing your rules and at what
level
they might situate themselves at so
the most basic for tabular data which is
what this
uh talk is all about
validating tabular data um the cell
value
uh level uh validation could be
something like
the date format not aligned to um
what the app or the software expects uh
something that goes and outside the
range of legal values
building up from that you can extend
these things to the entire column but
also add other
um other validation um
rules that have to do with maybe the
mean having to be close to certain value
or an
exact value mentioning things
consistently
rather than varying throughout an entire
column if
you're referring to the street all the
same but not basically using
alternative forms for the same value um
at the row level um this i feel is
maybe not quite as common but packages
that i'll go over
shortly have to do with that as well so
if you are interested in maybe
validating a data set based on
some multivariate distances that go by
row
you will be able to do that as well
again
if it's relevant to whatever you're
trying to achieve or build
uh interestingly enough you can set up
validation rules that have to do with um
bivariate or multivariate uh rules as
well
um so anything like correlations or
things that logically wouldn't make
sense but you want to make explicit so
that anything unusual
does get flagged quickly so for instance
in a data set
where somebody has an age under 16
yet they seem to have a full-time job
that immediately tells you that
something has gone wrong there and you
would be able to actually formalize this
into a validation role
in the packages that i'll mention
shortly uh also
uh final ones uh you might have some
rules that refer to a full
data set uh or even cross data sets
depending on whether you have to merge
them or anything like that
so having mentioned all this stuff what
are some
dedicated r packages that handle
validation issues well
first of all the example data set that i
chose to illustrate all these
packages is anscombe's
quartet this is quite famous and i'm i'm
guessing
a lot of people maybe everybody will
have heard of this but just in case
anybody hasn't
um the main idea here is that
across these eight variables if you pair
them up two
by two the correlations are always the
same even if
uh the numbers themselves are uh really
quite different
in fact even from the help file in in r
itself
um you get this really nice explanation
of what the whole
um idea is about and
very very handy for us um you also
actually get straight up some
some rules that have to do with this
data set that we can use as validation
rules which is exactly what i've done
and what follows
so with that in mind um oh
yeah i had forgotten about the slide uh
basically this just goes to show that
depending on
or regardless of how different the the
four
sets of data are um the um
[Music]
the regression line will be the same so
that's the whole idea behind
this this data set but that's not
exactly what we're interested in
just now uh so
first package in the lineup is uh
validate
and uh in some way it's i hope it's fair
to say that it's slightly the
odd one out and you'll see why the the
way the syntax looks here is basically
um under the banner of
a check that function you are able to
specify
all your constraints for the data all
your expectations
so exactly what i've been saying
previously um
stuff like at the level of the entire
data set that this should always have
eight columns
um that various um
equality rules should always be followed
[Music]
validate also lets us set up variables
on the fly
and then basically end up specifying
relationships between them
what i've also done here is basically
set this up to fail
already just so you get an idea of what
you can expect from this package in
terms of its outputs whenever some of
your expectations
are wrong so what that means is you get
something like this you get this
table that has um
in this case all the 15 um
rules that i specified uh as part of the
previous slide
um interestingly enough errors are all
false
yet there are some fails what this means
is um the fails
pretty much count all the instances in
which
the data actually deviated from the
rules that we specified
now the errors here would only have
appeared if say
in the previous slides instead of
x4 i would have mentioned some variable
that actually doesn't exist in the data
set
whatsoever so it's not errors in terms
of
validation failures but rather in terms
of specifying the validation rules
themselves
um which is what sets this apart from
all the
the next packages that i'm going to talk
about um
something else you can do with this
packages create these sorts of
visualizations
that tell you just how much the data
deviates from
each given rule that's kind of it in a
nutshell
in terms of validate um in terms of
assert r
which is the next one i have lined up um
things are organized um slightly
differently first of all we have these
general
verify uh verbs that can either apply to
rules that have to do with the entire
data set so does it
add here to the naming convention that
we expect for this data set so we
already know these columns must exist in
there we can specify that
we can verify whether the numbers of
rows and columns are what we think they
should be
then at the level of individual values
we have a bunch of things that we might
want to
verify like these equalities and so on
but we can go even further than that and
we can actually specify things
by column and by row things are maybe
slightly confusing here or at least
i thought they were in terms of
this assert verb might sound very
general especially based on all the
principles that i mentioned towards the
start but actually
what this means in the context of a cert
r
is it quite simply only looks within
columns
to verify whether the conditions that
you specified
are true but if you want to actually
look within columns
and only evaluate the condition
after the entire column has been looked
at rather than
go by values within a column if that
makes sense then you use
insist instead it's slightly
complicated um and we have the same
parallel versions
of assert and assist but that go by rows
rather than by columns
this is actually a really powerful
package in that it works hand in hand
with the second one that is called
assertive
and that one has a huge huge variety of
um checks that you might want to
to use one that i just threw in here
just for demonstration purposes is
we want to make sure that wherever this
is running is
a linux system but it there there's so
much variety in this package this is
just something i happen to choose
um first point or another point of
departure from the previous validate
package is what we're seeing here
is no longer an output of
uh a summarized output of how much
the data set is deviating from our rules
or not we actually have the data set
itself
and this is much more in line to what
some resource like code complete would
uh would say so as long
so long as the validation checks um
are passed then no errors occur
everything is silent and you basically
can propagate this data which is now
considered to be fine
because it adheres to all those rules
you can propagate it further
through whatever system you've built
like a shiny app or what have you
um however if things fail
uh like i have set things up to do
right here so uh 12 is not the number of
rows of this data set
and also this wasn't working on windows
at the time
so what this leads to is two
errors that have occurred and now
instead of being able to continue
with data that is actually shown to
deviate from our expectations
we have to stop in our tracks and do
something about these errors
which is exactly what you want uh
something else that i'd almost forgotten
to mention
if you want the entire set of rules to
be followed
and to be tested against the data
then you must actually for this package
you must include a chain start and a
chain
end without these what will happen is in
this
case things will fail on line five
because there aren't 12 rows
and any other subsequent errors won't be
captured anymore whereas
if you ideally want to see all the ways
in which your data deviates from your
assumptions you need to
fit a chain around all these rules
basically
so that's that package ensure
[Music]
probably just to dive in uh straight to
the point of
where this one um shines
is the fact that um you're able to
um specify a template
for the correct data that you would
expect and then any new incoming data
uh you're able to compare against that
fixed template
so something that um you're able to
um to set up in terms of the template is
any data that you're satisfied actually
follows all the rules
um you've you've set up
you're able to basically get rid of all
the rows under that but what that leaves
with
is basically an empty structure but
which still preserves
things like the column names of course
the number of columns
and importantly the classes of all of
these things
so that's exactly what ensure allows us
to do here basically say
for any new and incoming data we want to
compare if the names are the same as our
fixed template that never changes
as well as going column by column if the
classes are still the same for all of
these things
so that's that's something we actually
ended up using because this is a really
uh cool feature um that's probably the
key thing to mention about
this one and again much like in the
previous uh
case assuming all goes well nothing
terrible has happened with the data
then you simply get all the data set um
returned back to you so that you can
keep using it further in the pipeline
but if that doesn't happen what you end
up with
is some errors again in this case ensure
by default
will save all the errors it encounters
as opposed to having to specify a chain
start and a chain
end so
uh kind of halfway through in terms of
the the r packages
next one on the list is checker um
this one i
thought was had some really interesting
characteristics here so it makes it very
easy to check overall
characteristics of the data set but as
far as i've been able to tell
it's more difficult to check individual
column characteristics so um that's
that's something to bear in mind as
opposed to the other
options that i've mentioned previously
also in case you might be tempted to
think that
x1 x2 and all the rest of them are
all constants of ten thousand that's not
how this package operates what this is
really saying
is whatever happens to be in the x one
uh variable here it's of the class
numeric just the same as this number
that i supplied to it
you're only able to be super specific
about
when something belongs to a set like
x3 here but otherwise
you can't actually specify ranges or
anything like that
in this values argument also in the same
check data function you're not able to
specify the correct
total number of columns interestingly
enough
um but again following the same sort of
uh rule checker just gives you back the
entire data assuming nothing else has
gone
wrong um oh yes
something that's important about this
package though remember
the entire list of criteria that i
mentioned towards the start about
looking for validation at the level of
either
rows column cells what have you this
package does have functionality that
lets you validate
things like uh merges between data sets
so that's that's one thing to note
okay point blank um this one
is really quite interesting in terms of
being able to generate a
really nice detailed report uh
this might be very useful to you if
let's say
you want to have a nice interactive
interface
um where if somebody let's say
uploads data that doesn't uh respect
whatever
rules you've set up it's much easier to
actually
show them how this data deviates so that
they can fix it rather than just give
them
an error that they depending on their
background they might not know
what to do with so that's kind of uh one
of the
the highlights of point blank
what we do in here is basically supply
all of our rules again as part of
various
functions and all these are sandwiched
in between
this create agent and interrogate
um functions so those are the ones that
actually generate the report
based on the evaluation of all these
rules that we've specified
so what this looks like assuming
everything
goes okay which it has done in this case
this report goes by rule by rule
and gives you some details about uh
whether things fat
passed or failed and then how many cases
in the case of whether or not a column
exists there can
only be one pass or one fail however for
things that go
at the level of individual values within
a column then you're going to have
let's say 11 passes in this case with
there being 11 rows in this data set
so that's kind of the overall look of of
this report when things go well
when things don't go well
you might end up getting errors again of
this nature
you do get again two errors you don't
have to
worry about things not being captured in
case there are multiple
validation failures also
if we re-add the create agent and
interrogate functions again sandwiching
all the
rules even if they fail this time the
way that will impact
the report that you get at the end is
you get this really
convenient type of button where you can
specifically download the cases where um
these these rules are basically broken
now
in case like if like in here on row
20 uh i had specified a bogus rule that
the number of rows in this data set is
60.
so because this was actually not the
case
in terms of uh what happens when you
click the csv download button
it'll give you the entire data set back
so depending on how much data you have
that
may or may not be an issue so it's
something to be aware of
okay so ruler um
what was this one about yes so this
one has a considerably different syntax
from everything else i've shown you
before
uh long story short basically you create
these
packs of rules that can refer either to
the
entire data set maybe i don't want or i
don't expect this data set to have
any missing values ever depending on how
it's created maybe that's
that's justifiable i wanted to have
certain
classes and all of these things i can
stick into a
uh general data pack of rules
i can do the same thing with a
cell pack that has various individual
rules for the values and then basically
i expose the whole data set
to all these packs and see if anything
breaks um again same as before you get
the whole data set back assuming
everything is fine
if things are not fine like in this case
where i set it up to
fail just so that we can see what could
happen um
you end up getting uh a error and
additionally a
report if you choose to set things up
that way
as well um in terms of the final
dedicated package that i that i
investigated for
uh for this talk the final one is
checkmate and
you'll have noticed at this point
probably that all the previous packages
tend to just uh pipe together and
connect together
all sorts of um
related rules that we have for the same
source of data
whereas in this case uh checkmate seems
to be more
uh dedicated to preconditions
uh for a function so basically if you've
written a function that
is supposed to take input that looks in
a very specific way
then you're going to be able to set up
all these little
assertion statements that look at
various bits and pieces
or various requirements that you need
for that function to run
and assumes will be the case and the
data you supplied to it
so that's where these come in handy as
kind of disconnected little
checks
so what you'll get here for each of them
is
an error or they'll be silent
if things actually go well and actually
follow your your assumptions um
okay so after all of that um
the the one thing i wanted to really
kind of point out is that
you needn't uh think in case you do
um that just because you need to do
to carry out validation you need a
dedicated validation
package there are various other ways to
handle the same
sorts of issues depending on what your
needs might be
so based on that something that we ended
up
using in an app is actually just the
read underscore csv function that allows
you to specify
um on top of column names and themselves
their types so this is maybe not
appearing necessarily
as handy as everything uh i've shown you
before but it might be
at least in terms of how we set things
up using um
reader what we did after specifying
our expectations for all the data that's
supposed to come in um
we kind of created two two streams of
possibilities basically if the number of
parsing problems as specified by all of
these
uh these types that we mentioned above
is above zero then basically
the user of this shiny app which is what
it was
would see something like found this
number of parsing errors
in whatever columns and then they would
basically
have within their grasp a way to deal
with the
the issue go back to the kind of
hypothetical
drawing board fix their upload and then
try again basically having been armed
with this this information about
why things didn't work uh
if everything seems to go fine and
things parse
normally uh without any any particular
output in this
problems uh function then continue with
whatever
you wanted to do with that data anyway
so there are multiple
ways to handle validation again it just
kind of depends on what you're going for
and a really good starting point is just
having an idea of
um what is out there so that you can
just make an informed decision about
what works best for you
um and this is exactly the sort of
output from
problem so basically because i set
things up
things up to fail um and specify that y
two which is actually just a regular
numeric variable should be a date
all the values within y2 are now flagged
as problems
therefore the output of this is not null
we have an issue we can flag an error
that is as helpful as possible to the
user so they can fix things
okay almost there um in terms of
conclusions so after having gone over
all that stuff uh what's what's the key
the key message uh what is their uh
left here as a take home um message
so one of them is the fact that after
having discussed all the
uh dedicated validation packages uh as
well as an extra tool
maybe something like uh read csv
combined with a number of problems when
reading
um i'd say a good
a good conclusion from all that
discussion is that there is not
necessarily a one-stop shop
one dedicated tool you can use it's okay
or perhaps even necessary to customize
depending on what you want to do
um the other essential thing i wanted to
um to emphasize and hopefully i managed
to get across
is that data validation teaches you to
think
defensively and a really important
concept in code complete is that
by teaching you how to think about
programming
that allows you to code into a language
not in it the distinction being
that regardless of what language you
happen to be using
as long as you have these uh really
healthy
guiding principles you'll actually
manage to translate those
into whatever language you need to be
working with
um again
related to the defensive programming
idea your code will be more robust if
you do things this way so
again assert things and handle the
errors as i was saying towards the
beginning of the talk
um kind of a byproduct of this entire
process is the fact that you're forced
to think more deeply about what you
assume about the data and check that
you've actually understood the data
um as deeply as you can in order to
formulate all these rules in the first
place
sometimes especially under uh time
constraints you might just
think something looks okay but unless
you take the
amount of time necessary to write these
rules
things might just not um register
and something that is not actually okay
might slip past you
um and finally but i guess last but
not least um the fact that
more often than not at least in my
experience a data scientist
isn't the person who is generating or
isn't the custodian of of the data so
by actually even attempting to formalize
all these validation rules that i
mentioned
by definition you have to go to the
people who actually own the data
and work very closely with them to try
to figure out
what makes sense to code into a
validation rule
and that's actually uh been a really
good process for us working on a project
recently um yeah i think at this point
this is this is all i had to cover
i did uh go very slightly over the
the time limit but hopefully that's okay
um and yeah i'll uh stop sharing now and
let jared jump back in thank you
everyone
thank you katarina uh we haven't figured
out how to do a
a virtual applause everyone just
applause in place give a golf clap or
something
uh so thank you everybody uh thank you
katarina for that wonderful talk
so we had a few questions rolling um you
know john sabine's in the chat clap clap
he's least typing out cloud club that
works thank you john
cool thank you all right so first up
um can you talk more about the assist
function uh the person said i slipped by
them a little bit
how i guess that's different than the
assert okay
let me let me quickly have another look
at those slides
okay right so that was in
a cert r um i'm thinking maybe i should
um let me see
share the screen again
okay so hopefully that's visible now yep
yep uh so insist is basically doing
uh a very similar job to
assert but the difference is here that
in order to
figure out for instance whether you have
any
outliers in a given column you can't do
that by
on a value by value basis within the
column
so the way this package works is it
needs to distinguish in between
when you look within a column but cell
by cell
as opposed to looking at all the values
within that column
jointly to try to figure out whether
something is a is an outlier for
instance
so that's when you would use assert
versus insist even if both of them
conceptually are related to columns
i hope that made sense so assert is
vectorized and insist is like a summary
function
yeah perfect thank you
so this is a more of a general purpose
question about this and there's a few of
these
how do you choose which package is best
for your data validation work i know you
said there's no one-size-fits-all
but do these packages fit neatly into
the validation methods you discussed in
the beginning
well not exactly so this is this is the
sort of struggle
i also had when trying to figure out
what to actually
and what we ended up building so
[Music]
it depends uh it's possible this example
with
an anscombe's quartet was slightly
contrived your actual
real life data might have
way fewer constraints than this you
might just be interested in
having only a minimum and a maximum
value
allowable and just some fixed column
names
and that's it and then if you have
something as simple as that
then i don't think it particularly
matters what you use
there's going to be a lot of overlapping
between these packages so
it doesn't really matter having said
that
one issue where um and to be
to be fair i don't actually know the
full answer to this this myself i only
glanced at this and i can't remember
which package
actually had some data on this but most
of them don't seem to
for very big data sets depending on your
definition of very big
i don't know if one of them might emerge
as being the most efficient
so that's something you might want to
take into account but again it's
probably going to be a trial and error
type of thing depending on
what your data looks like and if you
just end up using
one of them over the others and saying
that it seems to work
then that's one thing um
the other thing is when
we ended up having to look at how to do
to carry out validation on our data sets
when that entire situation came up with
the
date formats and all the rest of it at
that point
it was really quite late in the game
when we had to integrate all this
so it was already
that ship had kind of sailed almost in
terms of integrating some kind of
neat one single package solution because
all sorts of code already pre-existed
this
read csv code was already there
to deal with the with the uploads
and it's only at that point that we
realized oh wait
actually within the read csv function we
already have what we need to do the
validation that we're interested in
so we didn't need to go looking for a
specific package to deal with say
making sure that the date column
always exists and actually has
a date class because that was already
handled with that so i guess
it just depends so much on what exactly
you're trying to do
that it kind of is a trial and error and
go explore sort of thing i was hoping
i am still hoping that by just giving
you an overview of what's out there
i'm just going to help you along and
figuring out which of these might work
best for you
great and to follow up on that question
something in a similar vein
would you say that the insurer package
is the closest to
you the best when practicing offensive
validation techniques
uh ensure um
not really because uh with the exception
of
a valid date that doesn't actually stop
your in your tracks
if something fails it'll just summarize
the extent to which things fail as a
table but it won't stop
a pipeline from continuing with bad data
um all the rest of the ones actually
have this functionality
of asserting a thing and if that happens
to be false
uh throwing up an error so that that
won't be the
uh specific um advantage
of ensure what insurer does use nicely
and we did do later is um
did implement in our project is it
allows you to have this kind of
fixed golden standard that is empty
though
of what the data structure should look
like in terms of
column classes um and column names
so that's that's one thing that that's
really good for
and speaking of packages do you don't
have to assert that
um so i haven't
looked at this one um i think it was
mike
sorry it's been lost to history yeah
potentially
um i'll have to actually go back and
look at that because
i remember seeing it but for some reason
i
i can't remember why i didn't include it
so
sorry about that one um
yeah i'll have to go back and check what
what the situation was there
um what i do remember noticing is
assert r and especially if you combine
it with assertive
there's so much there that
it's almost overwhelming so i guess if
you if you wanted just something
really broad because you had a huge
variety of conditions you wanted to test
you're likely to probably find them
in this duo uh but in terms of assert
that i can't actually remember where
that fits in with the rest of the story
and everything else i mentioned okay
somewhere there's like two came out at
the same time like assert that and
assert r and
one might i guess maybe start that
disappeared
then we have a question about system
dependencies is it possible if any of
these packages or maybe
another one to validate that a system
dependency is present like
lib curl 2 is lib curl is installed or
lib xml2
or should they just use file.exist to
check that
okay that's a great question um
again there were
system related or yeah actually
uh whether or not dependencies exist
whether or not
files exist all these things i am 99
sure lived and assertive which is pretty
massive
so yeah for anything like that that
doesn't have to do
with um a data set itself
i think this one is out of the whole
bunch your best bet to go
digging uh into okay so assertive folks
for anyone who missed that yeah
yeah cool um there's another question
about
how do you parse the output from the
summary reports to be able to
programmatically make decisions on
whether to continue or not
how do you parse it how do you get the
information out of the summary reports
like some of these generate these
reports well
do you let them go through do you let
them not is there like are they data
frames the reports
so that's the thing i i probably
wouldn't do anything based on the
reports themselves i'd probably work on
the um
errors themselves one thing i didn't
mention earlier is some of these
packages
um let's see if i can actually find an
example here somewhere
uh so that what i say will actually make
a bit more
sense um yeah so this is another
thing having to do with ensure but i
don't think it was the only one but
it'll just
um serve the purpose of showing you what
i mean um
whenever something fails uh one of these
tests
for some of these packages this one
included you can actually
type up your really pretty looking um
error message yourself so that if you
wanted to
you could actually use this and inform
users of what's gone wrong without
something looking very
cryptic and horrible
so once you have something like that set
in place
i don't know that i would use any
reports to actually do anything in the
let's say server side of a shiny app
i would just go by the fact that some
error existed and decide
by that what the report would really be
more useful for
is sending it off to a human for extra
details if they
need it but in terms of what the app's
behavior should be like
i don't think that should depend on
a report or a summary but just
whether or not something failed in the
tests if that makes sense
makes sense to me hopefully it makes
sense to the person who asked the
question
great and then there's a few other
questions that you actually
answered and if you're like oh never
mind she answered that so
we don't need to go through those
anymore i guess because you answered
them so
good job yeah yeah
um there's a question not for you but i
see a mata is asking it to luda
about joining our ladies um i and i i'm
not asking you to just join you just
join the group and attend a meetup so
yes we highly encourage everyone who
wants to go to it uh go join our ladies
that way
great yep yep that nothing to do with
you that was something in the chat
window so
um okay i'll give a last minute chance
we went through a lot of questions i'll
give one last minute chance
to see if anyone wants to throw or throw
a question at katarina
otherwise we will oh there is a question
see it's always good to get that last
chance
um then we'll go through and call the
random names or who's going to win the
prizes
all right so we have a question in terms
of error messages do those neatly come
up in modals
like if you're doing this in shiny can
you put them up neatly in a modal
yes that's exactly what we did uh so
assuming you can still see my screen
over here
um this is kind of
almost pseudo code at this point because
there was too much to include but i
tried to include as much as possible to
actually
give you an idea of how this this thing
was coded
so in this particular example let's say
you read the csv that was just uploaded
by a user and see
whether or not any parsing problems
appear
if they do the number of problems here
will go
above zero and if that's the case you
see something like this
right so once you have this output from
problems from the from the upload
um you can build some nicer
text around that so what we did was
something like this
uh you could say found
in this case oops uh i found 11
the number of rows here uh parsing
errors and columns
the column the unique column being y2
um please check the upload correct any
problematic values and try again
and this is general enough that it'll
work for
uh sort of anything that the output in
here
sorry uh throws up at you so it could be
something like
uh found uh 20 parsing errors if this
had 20 rows
across columns y2 and y3 if that also
happened to be present there
um so you can craft things
in a way based on this at least uh
that you get a nice um character
at the end of that um or string that you
can save
instead or at least that's what we did
here save instead of the actual upload
itself
then later on somewhere in the uh server
function you can check whether or not
uh this upload thing is still
a data frame or a table or whatever it's
actually supposed to be
versus a character and if it's a
character then you'll know that that's
actually an
error message and something went wrong
in that case
you can stick it into a sweet alert or
something like that and actually show it
to
the user so that they know what to do so
that's kind of what we ended up
uh doing i don't know if there might be
a
better way to handle things but that's
how we designed it
okay that'll make dina tali very happy
for those who don't know dean natalie's
like
out of toronto there's like huge shiny
users so he'd be very happy to hear that
yeah i think he actually worked on one
of the um
either shiny alert or alerter packages
sweet alert something like that
yeah one of those is is his true
yeah okay
so shiny alert and shiny he would
definitely wear shiny js and get shiny
alert
and there's another one called no sweet
alert r never made it to crayon because
dean's package superseded sweet alert or
something like that
right yeah so i i think we did use
deans actually so there you go yeah dean
writes a lot of good stuff
okay so it seems like
we are out of questions so we are going
to do some giveaways just to close it
out
so we could let i was gonna say we could
collect katarina draw names at random
uh that might put her on the spot
because she has to search through the
list
yeah all right i want to just take it
easy now do nothing
yeah so in the spirit of that to make it
easy on you i'm gonna let amada
fly through here now here's the thing
folks you have to be
i guess unless amada has a list from
earlier or do you have i don't think you
have email addresses
no i wanted to reward people who stayed
till the end
perfect so pull through people so what's
gonna happen folks since we don't have
uh necessarily access to all of your way
to contact you if a model calls out your
name
you're gonna have to be in contact with
us all right
um um uh a lot of modified how you get
in contact over there there's so many
different ways slack email whatever
um books we have to give away um it'll
be anything public
so john it's dean atali a t a l
i um anything from o'reilly's on virtual
for
digital books ebooks is up for grabs you
win
you tell us which ebook you want you get
it and then we're going to give away one
of those
and then two books from pearson um you
have a choice of i believe they're
virtual books right i'm out of not the
physical books
yes they're ebooks you have three
options three options you have my book r
for everyone
dan chen's book pandas for everyone and
was the third the deep learning
illustrated yes
and um john kronz who spoke at the
conference recently
um deep deep learning illustrated
so those so if you win one of the
pearson prizes you could choose between
those three ebooks
and if you win the o'reilly prize any
ebook they have i guess
so amada search for lucky winners
sure and the o'reilly one is anything on
their website but
it has o'reilly has to be listed as the
publisher so almost anything on their
website
cool so um all right going to choose a
random
katherine uh
okay um mark platts
and millie sims
okay catherine mark platts milly sims
you've now have to get in touch with
ahmad i might have to want them talk to
you on slack email
but how do you want to get in touch with
you so um
either here in the zoom chat you can
send me your email or if you are in the
slack channel
i'm a mother i should be at madash r
meedup
uh or amala our conference
great thank you all right
thank you amada for uh drawing the names
uh
thank you katarina for the excellent
talk thanks for having me
very happy to have you here maybe one
day we'll have you
in person in new york city yeah i would
love that
yes yes uh so
everyone uh thank you congratulations
winners remember next month november 9th
december 1st 2nd 3rd and 4th and we
already have actually speakers lineup
for the next three months in the new
year
we'll announce those as we get going uh
so big virtual round of applause for
katarina and we'll see everyone
virtually next time hopefully one day in
person soon like having catering in new
york hopefully we'll have everyone's
in person i look forward to that yeah
great thank you
all right thank you so much